Hãy hai người ba tháng 7 năm ngày hủ chăm 5 năm, thông tin từ bình Việt đã qua tình quân ngày 2,
đơn vị vừa tiếp hiện cấp cứu một chẻ nhỏ bị hóc gì vật là hả nhá?
Thưa đó, chương ngày 2 năm ngày hủ chăm 5 năm,
qua cấp cứu tiếp hiện bình gì lời lời lời lời á,
hai tuổi chú xa còn bài, tình quân ngày trong tình trạng quyết mất ý thức,
nương tờ, tìm tại tạng thân, theo ra định bình gì,
chứ đó bè ăn nhắn vào bất lời bị hóc.
Sau khi thầy chẻ có giấu hiệu hóa thở,
vui nhà đã đưa đến bình Việt.
Dù đã được các bác sĩ nỗi lực cấp cứu như bình gì không qua khỏi,
rất thử dân đưa đi cấp cứu quá mỗi.
Hì bị hóc gì vật chẻ dễ bình nương tờ,
nương tên chỉ sâu phải phút nếu không được sự chỉ đúng cách.
Dù đó, khi chẻ có giấu hiệu bị hóc gì vật,
trên đối không đưa tay móc họng nếu không thể xị vật sã dàng trong việc,
vì có thể khiến xị vật chui sâu hơn và vơi thắc hoàn bản.
Với chẻ dưới 2 tuổi, nên đã út mà xuống tay, đầu thấp hơn nực,
dôi dùng lực vũ mạnh nhiều lần vào lương dự 2 xương bà vài.
Nếu không vụ quả thị lịch vừa chẻ và nực nhiều lần,
vừa chẻ lơn hơn đứng sau chẻ, ông ngang bụng,
dùng tây ấn mạnh và nhang vào vùng thưởng vị dưới xương ước để tổng gì vật sã.
Cần đưa chẻ đi cơ sởi tế vật nhất này sau đó,
kể cả khi đã lấy được gì vật.